aldam muham
[Silence]
m
oh
[Silence]
be
We are continuing in
our more comprehensive approach to
Z of course the book Z is the book that
we've been reading for quite a while
now our class therein was interrupted
a little bit by covid for a while and
some other things that came up but
alhamd
it's been a very fulfilling fruitful
journey in my
estimate and the entirety of the book is
about the messenger of Allah Muhammad s.
wasallam that's the subject matter and
it's not just one or two things about
him pretty much everything that we know
about him in
summary everything that
has bearing or anything that has
influence on Our Lives as Muslims as
devotees of Allah as followers of the
Prophet Muhammad s. wasam anything that
would be needed for us to know from his
Sunnah spoke of and explained and
elaborated and expanded on and so on and
so forth of course the book was written
while he was in travel and of course he
didn't have his books with him so he
wrote from memory
and there are more than
200 sources more than 200 references
different books that he quotes from in
his book Z so it's a compilation of
pretty much all of the knowledge or
significant books that were written up
to that up to that Century which was
the seventh century after Hijra that he
had got his hands on which went into
this Topic in this subject 200
references that's roughly there more
than that and one of those references is
the
book authored
by
so it is it behooves us to read the
book Z as it was intended to be written
in a spirit that it was written and that
is is that if there are
things that could be added to it for us
for our benefit we can go to those
references and continue to
learn and
so the chapters that we have taken
from and they're very
summarized one chapter we took regarding
the physical characteristics of the
Prophet Muhammad sallallah
was another chapter regarding his
etiquette and a third third chapter
regarding his miracles that Allah
subhanahu waala bestowed upon him and
blessed him with and sent him with and
performed through
him we were mentioning or we were
with when he
reached the section in this chapter
regarding some of the prophecies that
the prophets that the prophet Sall wasam
prophesied and some of the things that
would happen in the future some of them
in the near future some of others in the
very distant
future
[Silence]
for
s
[Silence]
Allah subhah waala
man
[Silence]
for
we have one of the prophecies very
important for us to understand this
concept this articulates the Brilliance
of and the the incredible Insight that
he had into the narrations of the
Prophet Muhammad s. was that being
that he mentions as one of the Miracles
one of the
Prophecies of our messenger s. wasam is
that people will begin to allow their
minds to ask any
question they know no bounds No
Boundaries with regards to what they
think about and what they entertain no
boundaries of
loneliness no boundaries of
humility to the point that they begin to
believe that even Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala himself is subject to their
thought in their mind and their
philosophy and their logic and this is a
grave error
part of this is that inkari and Muslim
Abu narrates to us that the prophet
s
says that people will continue to
ask and they will say and another
narration that a Shan will incite this
type of thought who has created this who
has created that and the person all the
while will answer Allah Allah has
created this Allah has created that
and then he will pose the question and
being that Allah has created
everything who then has created
Allah we ask Allah subhah wa tala to
protect our minds and
hearts why is this a prophecy in our
time
today this type of question this type of
argument this type of
thought this mentality this attitude
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala owes us
to explain himself to us or that even if
he did explain himself to us that we
would be able to understand him that we
would be able to Encompass Allah
subhanahu
waala's attributes and descriptions with
our
minds this attitude was not native to
the Arab peninsula in the time of the
Prophet Sall alai
wasam all of the Arabs regardless of the
idols or false gods and deities that
they
worshiped they all
agreed that the creation has a creator
that Creator is
Allah and he is the creator of all they
didn't worship other than Allah because
they believed that other than Allah
created with him no they didn't even
worship other than Allah with the belief
that other than
Allah
owns any part or is The Sovereign master
of any part of that creation they
worshiped other than Allah seeking
intercession
intercession what is the idea of
intercession the idea of intercession is
that Allah subhanahu waala is too great
to forgive me for instance to forgive
you who are we rather we should gain the
favor of his
devotees his close servants the aah of
Allah as they
claim and they will essentially put in a
good word for us
right and they took this based on their
their own practices and that is
that
you know they imagine that Allah is
the Sovereign
King and that he has those who are close
to
him and that those who are close to
him May seek intercession or may
intercede on the on the behalf of others
with Allah if you have a king he has
courtier he has ambassadors he
has
ministers and if you or I know one of
these ministers we can't approach the
king directly we have to you know know
someone who knows someone who can put in
a good word for us with the King this is
the idea of course is incredibly F
flawed
logic why because first of all the king
in this
scenario in our world a
king no matter how much power it seems
that he has he is powerless without his
courtier and his ministers they are the
ones that make him
powerful and he needs
them arguably he needs them more than
they need he more than they need
him and so when they come to him
interceding on behalf of
someone you know your majesty this is my
cousin this is whoever this is so and so
you know he must oblige them because he
needs from them as well as they need
from him this is not the case with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
second of all the king it is not
possible for a human King on this Earth
to know all of the needs of all of the
people he needs to have these things
brought to his
attention Allah subhanahu wa taala does
not struggle with that problem he
knows everything that is and was and is
to
be and so this idea is very flawed in
itself Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is a
king yet his kingship is entirely
complete and perfect and
all-encompassing the King if we look at
Power the seduction of
power if you look through history if you
look through the anal of history and you
look at different Kings different
Emperors different people that were in
that position that assumed that
Throne were they very powerful or was it
not usually the ministers that probably
are more powerful than the king
himself because they're the ones that
have the connections they're the ones
that rally the troops they're the ones
that are the generals Etc the king needs
them as a matter of fact the king is
usually less powerful than his
courtiers
why because the
king he is the face that everybody
blames are you with me here he is the
face that everybody blames when
something goes
wrong everyone points to that
face and when things go right people
being that they are usually more
ungrateful than they are grateful will
as well point to that face however a
courtier a
minister he is the one who is making
these moves anything goes wrong he
absolves himself in the public eye
anything goes right he will have a
portion of that
benefit and if you look through history
and you see all the kings and Emperors
and leaders of the world throughout
history you will usually find that those
who held most Sway in the king's court
is usually not the king himself the king
is more or less a symbol that everyone
rallies around that's basically
it and
so
measuring the kingship of
Allah and comparing it to the kingship
of his creation is incredibly flawed
but either way this is why they
worshiped other than Allah it is not
because they felt that other than Allah
has the abilities of Allah or the
authority of Allah or any of these
things and so this idea that there is no
God or is there really a god let me try
to prove that there is a
Creator this was not something common
only the village
idiots in their time would say such
things the
fools no one of
prestige says says these things the
Arabs agree that there is a
Creator and so when the prophet
sallallah was tells and and you have to
remember they're so isolated most of
them have never left the Arab
peninsula visitors are so
scarce that to them Humanity at large
does not think this all of humanity
they've never met someone who thinks
like
this and so when they're told people
will start to ask such questions and
they will start to have such arrogance
and they will unleash their minds in any
direction it wishes to go this is one of
the
Prophecies of our messenger Muhammad
s
[Silence]
and S
wasam
[Silence]
subh
for
[Silence]
e
subh
so this issue of
giving boundaries to our
minds not allowing yourself to think
whatever you
want there is there thought that is
prohibited in Islam
absolutely
Allah subhanahu Waal tells us stay
away stay clear of much
suspicion as verily some types of
Suspicion is sinful is
sin he says in another verse do not
follow and pursue that which you have no
knowledge
[Silence]
ofh
Allah subhah
told when his
son was
drowning and invited him into the
ark and he said
and his son said I will go to a high
place a high point that will prevent
me from
drowning and no's son was drowned in the
flood was promised by
Allah that he would spare his
family but family here is in what sense
blood family or spiritual religious
family spiritual religious
family and so his son was Swept Away in
the
flood and asked Allah you have promised
me to spare my family and indeed my son
is of my
family and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
rebuked that question
and he
said your son is not of your family
indeed he is evil indeed and
soul so do not ask me about that which
you have no
knowledge I
hereby prohibit you that you indulge
in that which the ignorant indulge that
you become of those who are
ignorant this issue of the mind I should
be able to ask any question and on the
you know based on the on
the based on the idea and the faith that
there is an answer to every question I
ask and that that question must be
totally reasonable tailor fitted for my
mind in order for me to be convinced of
it this is a
disease there are things which a person
may understand and most of
what we experience in our existence here
on this Earth we will not
[Silence]
understand
Sal
[Silence]
for
the
[Silence]
for
this issue
of pure logic what is referred to as
logic correctly speaking it's referred
to as
logic but anything that contradicts
directly unharmonious the Quran and
Sunnah the revelation of Allah is it
logic or is it
opinion is
difference logic is irrefutable right
1 + one is two this is a fact everybody
agrees on that but these things that
philosophers say and that people who
come up with different arguments to
discredit the Quran discredit the Sunnah
even if they agree that the wording
yes we agree with affirming the wording
but we refuse what we refuse the meaning
as a type of rejection
and so this is not logic logic never
contradicts
Revelation true correct
logic rather this is opinion they just
call it logic it's not logic it is
opinion and we see the
result of those who use this mechanism
of
logic in order to reject the revelation
Allah and his
son his
son is being Swept Away in the
flood is in the
ark he sees his son and tells his son
come ride with us and do not be left
amongst the
disbelievers his son son spoke
logically the logical thing to do if
there is a flood is to do what go to
High Ground that's the logical thing to
do but that is not the logical thing to
do if Allah's Revelation says otherwise
that's positively
illogical and so he said I will go to a
high point in a mountain mountain such
and such I'm sure the water won't reach
that
high this is iic we all agree that going
to a high point is the correct
recourse the correct course of action
when fleeing flood
flooding however even that logic as
sound as it may seem is positively
illogical because it contradicts what
Allah has said no one will be spared but
those in the ark with
none and so he tried to go to that high
point this point he is physically
above what happened he was Swept Away in
the flood andam was
preserved The Arc is is a parable an
analogy for Revelation and guidance from
Allah even if we don't know how the ark
works even if we don't know what type of
wood it's made of or how it is sealed or
how buoyancy Works doesn't mean we
cannot benefit from it if we write in
it
contrary to opinion which contradicts
and stands in the face of
Revelation this it will spell out a
person's
demise it will spell out a person's
demise if it is not
according and harmonious with the
revelation of Allah subhanahu
[Silence]
waala
man
[Silence]
Sall alai
wasam he then mentions the prophecy
of one of the one of the
companions that he would live a
long
extra
extraordinary
life meaning that he would live long
enough to where all of the companions
have passed away and he is one of the
only companions left one of the only
people on earth Earth that had actually
spent time with the prophet Muhammad
s was one of the last companions along
with anik
and and others
which survived the death of all of
the other companions he is one of the
last companions to pass
way and the narration is
ined that the prophet
s said
to perhaps you will have a very long
life so inform Those whom you
meet such and such to the end of the
narration whoever ties a knot in his
beard or uses the dried
dung to to clean himself after
relieving himself or
whoever uses an amulet that I am
innocent of this person I disassociate
myself from this
person and
so narrated these things to us even
though he is a companion who has very
very few narrations in all of the books
of Sunnah why because others more
prominent than he were narrating the
fact that this narration comes to us
from the transmission of means that
he outlived everyone else to where this
narration cannot be found anymore except
with and this is one of the miracles
of the Prophecies of the Prophet
[Arabic recitation]
prophecy was that all the way back when
the prophet sallai wasallam first
arrived to
Medina what is the first thing that he
did when he arrived to Medina the first
order of
business building theid this was the
first thing that he
undertook this is the first project and
while he was building his
Masid he said to Amar who was carrying
mud bricks to build he said toar the
transgressing or the group which
transgresses more the furthest of the
two groups from truth they will be the
ones responsible for your
killing this is
roughly 40 years before this
happened
that was killed
by the army of Asam Western Army during
the
[Silence]
of another prophecy is that this nation
of his the Muslims after being one and
United will go on to become divided and
schisms and that because of this
division in belief and
adherence they will have fighting that
will occur and this of course came to
pass
[Silence]
can
Alina
another
prophecy was that a
fire a great fire a great
Inferno will
manifest in the land of Yemen that will
be so
intense and so incredibly
bright that it will cast
shadows in the land of
hij the land of hij meaning Mecca and
Medina and the scholars agree that this
happened in as a we mentioned in Min
this happened in the 7th Century
after hij year 600 and
such and was documented by the Muslim
historians and this occurred and
was later documented and the scholars
agreed that this is the fire that he was
speaking about s. wasam this this
narration is in bukari and Muslim for
those who wish to look into
it
[Silence]
Allah
ill